en un mundo que parecería estar
dividiéndose decidimos tomar medidas
vamos a lanzar ted en español por
primera vez en la historia de ted vamos
a tener un bloque entero de charlas en
otro idioma para celebrar este momento
histórico decidimos que vamos a
compartir con todo el mundo en vivo y en
directo td en español el 25 de abril
desde vancouver / en español tendremos
seis oradores de lujo uno de ellos es
ingrid betancourt que como sabrán estuvo
secuestrada por las farc en colombia
durante más de seis años en su charla va
a compartir que aprendió durante todo
ese tiempo jorge ramos en su charla va a
compartir con todos qué significa para
el ser inmigrante jorge drexler el
músico y poeta va a compartir con todos
la historia de una canción
tomás saraceno es un artista increíble
que desafía los límites de lo que
creemos que es posible
gabriela gonzález fue protagonista y
lideró uno de los grandes
descubrimientos científicos de los
últimos tiempos
isabel ven que es
el origen de la fiesta en las culturas
humanas y no tan humanas
entonces el 25 de abril esperamos que
nos acompañen en este gran hito que es
el lanzamiento de td en español
y